Çeviri: Sueda Bingol
Gözden geçirme: Yunus ASIK
Merhaba, tekrar hoş geldiniz.
Ben Kutay Berk Sezginel,
arkadaşım Canberk Gürol.
Bugün size farklı bir müzik
performansı sunacağız.
Bu müzik performansının en büyük farkı
sadece vücut hareketlerimizi kullanarak
müziği istediğimiz şekilde kontrol
edebilmemiz olacak.
Bunu Canberk yapıyor olacak.
Size önce kullandığımız
ekipmanları tanıtayım.
Canberk'in karşısında gördüğünüz
kızılötesi kamera,
Canberk'in hareketlerini dijital
sinyallere çevirerek
bilgisayara göndermeye yarıyor.
Bilgisayarda da kullandığımız çeşitli
müzik programları,
istediğimiz müzik enstrümanını ya da
enstrümanlarını,
Canberk'in hareketlerine
atamamızı sağlıyor.
Bu şekilde Canberk kollarını veya herhangi
bir uzvunu hareket ettirdiğinde,
müziği istediğimiz şekilde
kontrol edebiliyoruz.
Birazdan, Canberk bize gösterecek
bunu nasıl yaptığımızı.
Bu performansı ilk defa
sergiliyor olacağız.
O yüzden bazı teknik aksaklıklar yaşıyor
olabiliyoruz bazen.
(Müzik sesi)
Evet, gördünüz böyle Canberk
kolunu kaldırdıkça
(Müzik sesi)
kullandığı enstrümanın sesi artıyor.
Sağa sola hareket ettirdiğinde de çeşitli
efektler katıyoruz sese.
(Müzik sesi)
Evet, başlamadan önce bize teknik destekte
yardımcı olan Mehmet Tayfun Başdaş'a
ve ışık ve görsellerde yardımcı olan
Yasemin Başdal'a çok teşekkür ediyoruz.
İyi seyirler.
(Müzik sesi)
(Müzik biter)
(Alkışlar)